what is going on everybody welcome to
part 6 of our Python with PI QT for
creating gooeys tutorial video series in
this video we're gonna be talking about
toolbars so the menu bar is like the
main menu kind of bar up here but then
you've got toolbars now I don't really
know if this has a toolbar but generally
the toolbars below the main menu and
it's a little bigger
and generally the objects on the toolbar
not always but generally will have like
little icons to them too so it's a
little thicker a little easier to read
and generally it's most applicable to
that page that you're on so with that in
mind
should we add the toolbar where we added
the main menu or should we add the
toolbar on the page specific to it we
should add it to the page that's
specific to it so going to home we're
just going to come underneath basically
the button up move and this is where
we'll add our toolbar so adding a
toolbar I think it's actually a little
easier than doing the menu objects
because many is generally or like
basically a menu is a drop-down and then
you've got options and you might even
have more options like here like recent
files stuff like that
so how might we do a toolbar so after
the quit button
I'll see that'll be fine it should be
out of the way at 100 pix maybe not I
think it'll be fun anyway but move
that's fine so now we're gonna have
we're just going to call extract action
again here and we're gonna say that
equals QT GUI Q app oops Q action rather
and then QT GUI Q icon and this is
basically how we can add an icon to the
toolbar now if you don't want to add an
icon that's totally fine I'll show you
guys what you can do there basically you
just would simply put the text here that
you wanted pretty much but will actually
end up doing one without the icon just
in case anybody cares later on so now
you with the icon because basically
what's happening here is you've got some
parameters okay so you've got it
the first parameter is going to be the
icon the
parameters gonna be what is it like the
hover text basically going to be and the
third is just the obligatory self so the
icon that we want to use
I think the icon that we should use
since we're using this choppa stuff is
let's bring this over here and we're
going to go to Python program and then
we're going to go a slash static slash
images slash two to chop it up PNG there
it is and we get this little little cute
baby right here and then we'll just
click and drag that into our the same
directory that we're in right now so
click drag boom now we've got to to
choppa PNG it's a good size 55 by 48
that's a good toolbar size and now we'll
just add in here to choppa PNG the next
parameter is kind of like the hover and
this one will just say flee the scene
and then our obligatory self next what
we're going to do is we're going to say
extract action dot triggered dot connect
what are we connecting it to self dot
close application we are no parameters
there if you put the parameters there
just for the record I know someone is
going to be like man every time I run my
application it just closes immediately
here's why all right you put little
parameters there what's gonna do is as
it loads this into memory it's going to
run this immediately so what we'll leave
this here for now and I'll show you what
I mean a little bit so now so that close
application extract action that's fine
now we need to create just like before
this is our toolbar kind of choice but
now we need to create the toolbar so
we're going to say self dot toolbar
equals self dot add tool bar and we
prajak ammo case this a camel casing
learn self that add toolbar and then
we're gonna say what what is this
toolbar that we're going to add we're
gonna add X Direction and then we're
gonna say self dot toolbar dot and
action
in and this will be extract action we
actually might not get away with this
tool let's run it and see what happens
oh we got away with it good stuff so
here we have our little uh general
yelling at us that we need to get to the
choppa so we click on him sure enough we
were able to exit no problem now let's
add these parameters really quick let's
run that and you can see that nothing's
happening you can't even see the window
pop-up it closes so fast so we can't run
module nothing happens but we're getting
spanned whoa so custom so again that's
why it's happening for anyone who is
like I don't understand it's not popping
up that's what so anyway that is that
we've got our tool bar we've got our
cool little baby now and we can extract
the application the other thing I just
want to show you really quick I think
it's pretty cool is what's let's run
some more time is this toolbar you can
see it comes with these little things
and oh my goodness we can move it around
a whole hot diggety obvious our quit
button is in a way but that's ok we can
move it down here oh my goodness we can
move it over here
holy smokes and then also if we hover it
you get that little text there's maybe
if you're not watching this on full
screen it might be hard to read it but
you should add the text too should say
flee the scene so pretty cool actually
that we not only do we have this toolbar
but we can move it around and it's got
this cool little animation when we do
and yes that is pretty awesome oh and we
can also move it off the window entirely
look at us we'll just put it over here
we quit it with the baby anyway so
that's actually pretty impressive that
we're able to create that toolbar with
like four lines of friggin code okay and
most of that is just defining like the
stuff that we want that toolbar is a lot
more code than that so anyway pretty
cool thank those QT guys and if you have
any questions or comments up to this
point please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time